today we're going to talk about the most
famous problem in game theory the
prisoner's dilemma
you and your partner in crime are
apprehended
but you're not too worried because the
police don't have much evidence on you
a clever cop tries to come up with the
way to get you to talk
he explains that if both of you stay
silent then each of you will serve one
year in jail
but he offers you a deal
if one of you confesses
then that person gets to go home free
and the person who stays silent gets
four years as punishment
however if both people confess
then each will have to serve your dues
to society and serve two years in jail
each
the cop leaves and separates you and
your partner so you're left wondering
what to do
you think that the best solution is if
you can trust your partner you should
stay silent
that way you each get one year in jail
and that's the best outcome for the
group
but you worry what happens if you stay
silent and your partner confesses
then you're gonna get four years in jail
and that doesn't sound too good
so you need to think about this more
logically
what you do is you imagine your decision
relative to your partner's decision
let's say that your partner confesses
you can either make the choice of
staying silent or you can confess as
well
if you stay silent then you'll serve
four years in
jail if you confess however you'll only
have to serve two years
so if your partner confesses it's in
your interest to confess as well
what happens if your partner stays
silent
well in that case if you stay silent
you'll serve one year in jail
but if you confess you'll go completely
free
so if your partner stays silent it's
also in your interest to confess
you come across a startling realization
that no matter what your partner does
it's always better for you to confess
this is known as a dominant strategy and
in game theory when you have a dominant
strategy you should play it
so you find the cop and you hurriedly
run over and explain to him that you
confess
the cop explains that
you're gonna serve two years because
your partner confessed as well
how did that happen well just as you
were thinking about the problem so was
your partner
he was wondering about his actions
relative to your decision
he thought what would happen if you
confess
and he had the choices between staying
silent and confessing
he realized that it was better for him
to confess if you confess
now if you stay silent he again realized
that it's in his interest to confess
so he has a dominant strategy which is
to confess
so far we've been thinking about the
game from one person's perspective at a
time
but truly we should be thinking about it
together as a whole when both people are
making the decision
they each have the choice to stay silent
or confess and that affects the outcome
for each person in the group
they can both stay silent
one person can stay silent while the
other confesses
or they can both confess
now it seems best for the group if they
could both stay silent they'll only
serve one year in jail and that's the
best that they could do as a whole
but as we showed earlier
it's better for you to confess no matter
what your partner does and is better for
your partner to confess no matter what
you do
therefore both of you will end up
confessing to the crime and serving two
years
this is the best individual outcome
that you can do if you can't trust your
partner and you have to make the best
decision for yourself
this situation is known as a nash
equilibrium and this is the crux of the
prisoner's dilemma that this is a worse
outcome for everyone
so the prisoner's dilemma is a conflict
between choosing what's best for you
individually and choosing what's best
for the group as a whole
and these two things are not equal
while you would like to do the best
thing for the group
you can't trust that other people will
also cooperate and do the best thing for
society so you have to do what's best
for you individually and that ends up
worse for everyone
the prisoner's dilemma comes up time and
again in our daily lives when you ask
your friends to volunteer for help
when you're driving and wondering
whether to speed
or when you're trying to save the
environment and asking others to be
green as well obviously we do win some
of these games and we can find the best
overall outcome for the group
this is a brief introduction to game
three and you have to learn that there
are ways to build trust
and overcome the prisoner's dilemma
thank you for watching please subscribe
i make videos on math and game theory
you can also check me out on my blog
mind your decisions i have weekly
puzzles on monday and game three posts
on tuesday and you can check me out on
twitter at preshtalwalker thanks